all right well let's jump into this
first story let's talk about some
authoritarianism yeah from tim cass
breaking steve bannon says at least 35
trump allies had their homes raided by
the fbi on thursday he was speaking with
charlie kirk harmeet dillon came out
said can confirm confirmed this happened
to many trump allies i know as well so
i'm wondering if it's actually more than
35 the quote here is there were 35 raids
last night ben and said and there's
another grand jury coming together on
january 6th the washington post reported
it 35 senior members of maga republicans
supporters of donald trump that the fbi
role rolled in on so i'm wondering you
know biden comes out and he says maga
republicans are an extreme threat
a lot of us were like oh that's their
campaign strategy right i wonder if it's
more than that that they want to prime
the american people say it enough get
enough of their bots and garbage
corporate press to agree right that way
when they start arresting people they'll
say oh but you guys know how bad it is
right
well it's hard it's hard to say for sure
right exactly what that was and and it
certainly you know could be okay this is
a campaign video and this is uh the play
right the the play for the midterm
elections well he can't claim to be a
unifier or any of this stuff anymore he
can't really run on any of his policies
so basically what's his only play left
is to gin up his own base by saying hey
the other side is so evil to get out the
votes for for democrats um kind of a
desperate attempt but i gotta say and
this is what i was was talking about the
other day when when that speech was
given on my podcast part of the problem
uh that i was saying look this really
reminded me
of like a george w bush 2002
speech
it had everything from like i mean the
creepy red backdrop the military members
like right behind him this was like it
seemed like a war drum
speech like if you remember you know 9
11 happened in september 2001 we invade
iraq in 2003 but the whole year of 2002
was this slow you know beating the war
drums pushing the war propaganda about
what saddam hussein is doing and it did
have that feel to it i think that look
let's just call it what it is
donald trump for
four years
was framed for treason by his own deep
state by his own intelligence uh
apparatus now that is kind of
a real
thing that that's something pretty
interesting that you have the cia and
the fbi and the nsa working to oust a
democratically elected president with
help from the corporate press oh yes
with help from the corporate press from
uh from social media from big tech from
the you know pretty both uh both parties
as well so
now what you're really seeing is that it
has definitely been deemed unacceptable
to the establishment for donald trump to
be re-elected i mean not re-elected
elected again whatever you want to call
it
think about that what a devastating blow
that would be for their narrative and i
think that after the fbi raid in
mar-a-lago
they went big
there's no i don't think they can do
that and not follow this up with
something big they can't just raid a
former president's house and then say
all right we didn't find anything it's
nothing they gotta go for it now so this
is you know again if bannon is is
telling the truth and this is what
happened this is another major
escalation in that step bannon's not the
kind of guy to to hoax like this no and
and harmeet dylan's a lawyer she's not
this hyper partisan i mean she's
obviously you know partisan in a certain
sense but
she's a lawyer coming out saying can
confirm this happened i i take it
seriously the the the thing i think that
we the general public should actually
look when they see this
okay cool you don't like trump you love
trump whatever thing you've fallen in
that space i think the thing that the
general public should really be thinking
about is
these are the
weaponization of entire intelligence
communities to go after presidents and
to slow somebody up for their okay i'm
going to go in again in o4
right so if they're doing that to
someone and that's their political
opposition that has resources that has
access that has all these other
different things the general public
should be thinking more so about do you
want to vote for a guy
come in a few years do you want to vote
for a party do you want to vote for a
system or group that has consistently
shown you because it's not just on the
left they're just the guys in charge the
democrats now and they're unhinged with
it like that whole mar-a-lago thing
adrian norman really he posted on his
twitter page it's like here right here
it's saying this was sent by biden
yeah clarence claren you know whatever
so this is
just to clarify this one's interesting
biden and may requested what the
documents they thought trump had were
yeah then they go and raid trump's mar a
lot like mar-a-lago with the feds you
know a few months later and so it's did
biden literally say i want you to raid
his house or did he go oh won't someone
please get me these documents and then
wink wink nudge nudge the feds went did
it i i think is
again like we were saying before camera
i'm past the point of believing that
this is incompetence agreed um it's too
it's too strategic you know
the sun rises and and if you're
depending on your location the sun's
right there every at this time the sun's
going to be here that is an organized
phenomenon it's too many oopsies and
because we're looking at
biden as this
you know the old dude that's struggling
with dementia and we kind of like that
might be the drunken monkey like i'm not
above this is a very intricate movie we
made this joke before that biden bumbles
and fumbles off stage and then as soon
as he's behind the curtain he stands up
the evil and he goes all right did they
buy it now let's go blow up some kids in
the middle east right well i but i also
think like whether it how much of it
went up to joe biden and how aware he
was it's almost irrelevant at a certain
point i mean we know it went to merrick
garland right so it's he already said in
his own press conference that this was
his decision so it went to very high
places i don't know if that's
at that point who really cares whether
it was the president or just his
attorney general right you know like
i think what's important too to
recognize with this is that it's not
even like really a left verse right
thing this is a power verse non-power
thing this is an establishment
anti-establishment thing i mean think
about the way the uh someone i disagree
with on a ton of things but think about
the way the establishment turned against
bernie sanders you know in in 2016
really rigging the entire election
against him in the democratic primary
think about the way in 2020 when he was
looking very good against joe biden they
were on msnbc and cnn calling his
supporters brown shirts and nazis what
do you think the system would do if
bernie sanders had been elected
president so some people clarify
they mounted a procedural effort against
bernie sanders like questions were being
given to hillary clinton in advance by
cnn in 2020 they had the three moderates
drop out and all endorse joe biden at
the same time so it's this it's this
back and elizabeth stay in right they
had her stay in so the one who was
splitting votes from him stays in all
the ones who are splitting votes from
joe biden get out and endorse biden so
it's it's it's this like
they they they flex and bend the system
so everything always skews in their
favor in those ways and what happened
and they did that with trump too but it
didn't work for once it didn't work and
that guy got in and so it's just the the
thing that should be eye-opening to
regular people is that you go look if
ever you supported a candidate from the
left-wing perspective who deviated from
the establishment too much they would
crack down on him in the same way and
the thing that the trump supporters
should be questioning about how how much
loyalty you have to donald trump going
forward is just like
donald trump appointed rey to the head
of the fbi he is the guy you know if his
mission his stated mission was to drain
the swamp well man he got drained by
that swamp he hired bolton right like
everybody went dude bolton pompeo bar
you know ray all of these guys his
entire team oh so he had no clue who to
trust and who not to trust and he got
rolled by although
he kept foundation on the job all of
2020. is that i cannot believe that
that's incompetence i i i do not believe
that that's incompetence and again
my job is to look at the general public
and saying hey
this doesn't this looks fishy and if you
see it from the left or the right or
whatever if this looks fishy is this
where you want to put your energy
locally state or federally do you want
to get behind those types of things
again because it's walking like a duck
bro it's been walking like a duck
looking like a duck for however long but
this is what's this is what we're seeing
right now
if the 35 raids on trump allies we're
watching a revolution happen we are we
are watching a political faction
with control of law enforcement
using it to crush political opposition
historically when you see things like
this happen it's typically how you end
up with a uniparty system now i think
for the most part there are democrats
and republicans for a long time have
been the youth party as it was with this
fake you know this this false
adversary right right right but
donald trump storms the gates trump
supporters bernie sanders supporters
tried storming the gates too bernie was
too nice of a guy i guess he was too
weak he couldn't he couldn't he couldn't
get in that ivory tower bernie sanders
walked up to the ivory tower with a
bunch of these lefties shake their fist
they say let us sin let us in and they
they spit on him and then he apologizes
donald trump they came with a battering
ram
then they bring in the big orange bull
who just rampages about
they want to regain control of the
establishment this is how they're
they're trying to do it by purging and
arresting all of their opposition
let me tell you real quick just how
scary it gets
they're going after trump supporters
they're going for trump people they're
not going after republicans the
republicans are going to be the
establishment but i'll tell you what
happened when i was when i was in egypt
when they had the second revolution
they realized that the the political
split between
the more secular type egyptians and the
muslim brotherhood was too great and
there was only one solution and you know
they did
you know what the military decided to do
to stop the the the constant revolutions
they had a revolution their revolution
again they just went and started killing
the muslim brotherhood they just went
out started arresting started firing
guns at and just attacking their their
their their protests
now it's not that bad they're not going
out and just killing trump supporters
but it's because we're in a different
degree of warfare that's third third
third generation now we're in fifth
they're using the power of law
enforcement to make sure trump's people
can't assist him and that his ideas and
his leadership are gone yeah well that's
it's interesting when you say we're in a
revolution and you could really think
about in the history of the united
states of america like we have kind of
this idea that we've had one regime
since 1776 but really there's been many
revolutions along the way i mean we had
a revolution where we overthrew the
articles of confederation and installed
the constitution um we certainly had a
revolution with abraham lincoln where we
fought a civil war uh i think you could
argue that uh fdr kind of was a
revolution my point would be here the
revolution was 2020. the revolution
isn't 2022. the revolution was having
the lockdown regime having what bordered
on a color-coded revolution with these
kind of like very um
let's say sponsored mass rioting and
protesting in the streets i mean this is
right out of the playbook of what we do
in other countries so this is the
follow-up to that yeah the 529
insurrection
when they went to the white house ripped
down the bridge injured dozens of
federal agents set fire to a guard post
set fire to a church and forced the
president into a bunker yeah and no one
talks about that right it's it's very
interesting right but so this is this is
the follow-up to that like if this big
push was made you could look at that
time magazine piece about how they stole
the election from donald trump if this
big push was made to to get trump out
and put joe biden in well this is now
the follow-up to that now how do you
this is usually after a revolution you
have this period where then you have to
crack down on the dissidents to make
sure that the the power that you took is
now this
it's all part of the revolutionary
process you mentioned the civil war
a civil war happens when factions fight
each other and neither side can just
take it right what we're watching now is
i don't know i don't care if it's
democrats it is the elite and they're
using and mostly as democrats and there
are some you know former republican
neocon types but they
what we're seeing is still the
revolutionary period so if in november
republicans win then the revolution is
not complete if in 2024 trump wins then
the revolution then the revolution
failed
right to some degree but sitting here
watching i i i
i can't believe that we have a story
that 35 trump senior trump people were
were raided by feds like that is such a
dramatic escalation i think they're
doing what's going to come out of this
is this is the streisand effect they're
doing something they're thinking about
we got to keep trump out they're not
thinking about the general public
watching going you guys are shitty
they're doing a lot of the heavy lifting
for us and i don't mean that in a good
way like oh great yeah raid more you
know mag extremists so-called and then
the people will wake up but that's kind
of like in a weird way what's happening
the general public how many times are
y'all are y'all hearing guys that may
have voted for biden and they fought you
tooth and nail and 20 whatever right 19.
yeah this is blah blah blah blah blah
now after a year and a half two years
they're like bro i i don't know i don't
really they may not be willing to say
yeah i'm going this way completely but
they're also going like nah something's
wrong here i don't even like how this
feels economically they're doing
something this massive over correction
that the general public is i think for
me
i don't think that anybody's just going
yeah we're going biden and i don't think
that they're going we're rating these
people and people aren't seeing i think
it would work if it was more clandestine
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you